Many have wanted to compare him to DONALD
TRUMP, but...
Poor old Donald Trump wishes he looked like
Berlusconi!
We could say that Berlusconi started from
nothing and conquered absolute power like
almost no one else in history.
He not only conquered political power in Italy.
He also amassed business power... and media
power.
If power corrupts, absolute power corrupts
absolutely.
And Berlusconi's life has many shadows...
but also many highlights!
To begin with, there is something that we
have to recognize about this man and it’s
something that, frankly, is enviable....
HIS ENERGY!
Think about it...
Berlusconi died on 12 June at the age of 86:
he was an old man.
Well, last year he appeared on TIKTOK with
this video.
We are not going to go into the message of
the video.
What I want to emphasize is that the man you
see was 85 years old at the time when this
recording was made...
when he was running again in an election...
in which he had a real chance of winning!
I don't know about you, but...
I wish I could reach the age of 85 with that
kind of energy.
That said, are we going to praise Berlusconi
in this video?
Of course not!
To speak of Berlusconi is to speak of corruption,
tailor-made laws and a political legacy that
is mediocre to say the least.
We could say that a good number of the problems
Italy suffers from – and they are not few
– are his fault.
I suppose that most of the obituaries you
read out there will also mention Berlusconi's
many sex scandals and his bunga bunga parties...
We are going to leave all that aside because
we are going to focus on two things: the political
and business profile of this man.
And, believe me, those two aspects alone would
be enough to make a movie.
In fact...
there is already a Berlusconi biopic and it
is a masterpiece: LORO, by Paolo Sorrentino.
Highly recommended.
For better or worse, Berlusconi has defined
what Italy is today, but not only that!
He also brought about a revolution in the
media throughout much of Europe.
That said, why does everyone know Berlusconi’s
name?
What is his political legacy?
Why do we say he has been revolutionary in
the business world?
Today we are going to answer these questions,
but first... let's take a look at a bit of
history.
The first difference between Berlusconi and
Donald Trump is their birth.
While Trump was born into a family that was
already immensely wealthy, Berlusconi was
born into a middle-class family in Milan.
Normal parents, normal education and normal
life.
However, Berlusconi had something special:
he was fascinated by show business and was
the best salesman you could find.
In fact, Berlusconi's beginnings were... as
a singer!
That’s right.
Berlusconi started his career as a crooner
who entertained parties on cruise ships and
the like.
Not surprisingly, that also launched his fame
as a heartthrob, but, as we said...
We are not going to focus on anyone's sex
life because we are a serious channel!
The fact is that by entertaining the Milanese
by night, Berlusconi made the contacts to
start his first big business project: MILANO
DUE.
A mega-development of 4,000 homes that was
an economic success.
But make no mistake!
What Berlusconi was really interested in was
not the real estate market but... the media!
In fact, Berlusconi's doctoral thesis was
precisely about the advertising business in
the media – by the way, his thesis gained
a summa cum laude...
In fact, in these early years of his career
we have to recognize one thing: he was a visionary.
We are about to find out exactly how.
(THE GODFATHER...
OF PRIVATE TV)
If you are watching this video from outside
Europe you might be surprised, but... there
was a time when private TV channels were banned
in most of Europe.
And no, we are not talking about Eastern Europe!
In the 1970s, television in Italy – and
in other countries like Spain – was a state-owned
monopoly.
That is, if you turned on the TV you only
had the channels of RAI, that is, the Italian
state-owned television corporation.
To give you an idea, in 1973, the Italian
government issued a decree prohibiting any
attempt to set up a private television station.
In fact, they not only had a monopoly on television
but also on television ADVERTISING.
And that was a very, very lucrative business.
Berlusconi was perfectly aware of this and,
therefore, his goal was to end this monopoly
in order to have his own national television
network.
The question is, how did he do it?
Well, pay attention, because this story is
worthy of...
A VisualPolitik video!
The first question we have to ask ourselves
is why was TV a monopoly?
Well, because of the radio spectrum.
At that time there was no digital television,
let alone the internet.
Television was broadcast by radio frequency
and the radio spectrum is limited.
In other words: there are not infinite frequencies
for everyone who wants to broadcast TV.
However...
around that time, a new technology for broadcasting
television emerged.
Cable TV offered enough space to broadcast
multiple TV channels.
The problem?
Not all homes in Italy were ready to receive
it...
Except for the homes of Milano DUE that is!
Exactly: Berlusconi arranged for his 4,000-home
development to have cable TV.
After a long legal battle, the Italian Constitutional
Court allowed the creation of private TV stations
broadcasting on cable... as long as they did
so only at the local level.
Well, Berlusconi had 4,000 households that
could become viewers of his own television
content.
This is how TELEMILANO was born.
A television station that was super local...
It was basically a neighborhood television
station!
Of course, TeleMilano was not the only local
television broadcasting on cable, but it was
one of the most popular because...
It had 4,000 captive viewers!
But wait because this is only the beginning.
Two years later, in 1976, the Constitutional
Court ruled again on the TV issue.
This time they allowed private TV stations
to broadcast by radio frequency as long as
they were only local.
That is, you could have a TV channel in Milan,
Torino or Rome... but not a channel broadcasting
nationally.
So what do you think Berlusconi did at this
point?
Well, good old Silvio was dedicated to buying
up all the local TV channels in all the regions
of Italy.
In a few years, he got hold of Roma TV, Video
Veneto, TeleTorino...
basically, he managed to get hold of all the
private TV stations in the country.
He united them into Italy's first media group.
In 1981, all these local TV stations changed
their logos to CANALE 5.
And that is how Berlusconi achieved what had
seemed impossible: to end a state monopoly.
Now he could compete head to head with the
RAI empire.
Thanks to having a national TV network, Canale
5 could sign the most popular public TV presenters
and pundits.
This is how the famous MIKE BONGIORNO left
the state-owned corporation for the new and
brand new private television company.
The strategy could not have been more aggressive.
Berlusconi wanted to storm the market and,
for that, he spared no expense.
He bought the most popular series in the United
States and even introduced Japanese anime
into Italian homes.
To give you an idea, between 1980 and 1981
alone, Canale 5 went from a turnover of 13
billion lire to more than 75 billion lire.
By 1987, Berlusconi's TV network already had
a 48% share of the screen time in the whole
country.
In case you are not yet astonished, remember
that only 15 years earlier, private television
stations in Italy were not even allowed by
law.
And this is a feat we have to give Berlusconi
credit for.
But if you thought that his business career
stops here, you are very wrong: after conquering
Italy, Silvio went on to conquer Europe, and
boy, did he do it!
Thus was born the MEDIASET GROUP, a company
that remains today, under the name MEDIA FOR
EUROPE, one of the largest media groups in
Europe.
Basically, this man was dedicated to buying
shares in many of the private television stations
that were beginning to emerge in other countries
around him.
And this is where we come to...
Spain!
Until 1989, private television was also banned
in Spain.
But in the 1990s, the government put an end
to the state monopoly.
And there was Silvio, also known as "il Cavaliere",
ready to enter with TELECINCO.
And here we come to the darkest part of Berlusconi's
business career: debt.
You don't build such a media empire in just
over 10 years without borrowing money from
half the world.
By 1994, FININVEST, which is the financial
arm of Silvio's empire, was the second most
indebted company in all of Italy.
So, at that point...
What do you think he did?
What's the next step when you've become the
lord and master of the media?
Well... pack up your things and leave the
company!
That’s right!
In 1994, Berlusconi gave up all his leadership
positions.
However, he kept all the shares in his empire.
Keep this fact in mind because it is important
for the next phase of the story.
But...
Where did Berlusconi go?
Well, we are going to look at that right now.
(THE POLITICAL CONQUEST)
Italian politics is really crazy!
It doesn't matter at which point in time you
are hearing this... it applies to any period
in history.
In this country, prime ministers last on average
2.5 years.
If you study Italian politics you will find:
conspiracies carried out by secret lodges,
state terrorism and, of course, mafias of
all types.
There was only one constant: CHRISTIAN DEMOCRACY.
We are talking about a center-right political
party that dominated the country throughout
the Cold War era.
However... in 1994, Christian Democracy was
dissolved due to a spiral of corruption scandals
worthy of a banana republic.
The right was orphaned... and the left was
not convincing voters.
But... where there are people willing to buy,
there is someone willing to sell.
And who knew how to sell better than anyone
else?
Exactly!
Silvio Berlusconi.
During the 1980s, he had publicly supported
the Socialist Party.
But now he knew that, if he wanted to win
elections, he had to switch sides.
And that's how he created his own center-right
party.
Although...
the truth is, we could say that it was a party
without ideology.
Basically, the process was as follows
What do Italians like more than pizza and
women?
Soccer!
And what do Italians shout when they support
their national team?
FORZA ITALIA!!!
Great!
Well, we already have the name of the party...
Ideology?
Well... we are for the good and against the
bad.
Who wouldn’t vote for such a party?
This is how, in 1994, the year of the World
Cup, Berlusconi created Forza Italia.I don't
need to tell you that Berlusconi won the elections
that same year.
And why, you may ask?
For three reasons: first, he had control of
the biggest television station in the country,
second...
the rest of the parties were killing each
other in internal disputes and third, we are
talking about one of the most charismatic
personalities ever known.
So this is how the most impressive political
career in Italian history began.
This does not mean that Silvio has always
won the elections.
Remember that Italian politics is chaos...
Even for him!
He has been prime minister in different interrupted
periods.
Now, we can say that Berlusconi has been the
politician who has governed Italy for the
longest period of time in recent history.
And we can also say that he has been the Prime
Minister with the most power.
Because he not only controlled politics but
also the media.
To give you an idea, according to estimates
by The Economist, in 2001, he came to control
91% of the screen share of Italian TV.
Think of it this way: he was the owner of
CANALE 5 and, at the same time, he dominated
State television.
Conclusion: the man who ended the TV monopoly
in the 80s ended up building another monopoly.
And this is where we come to the darkest part
of his life.
Because if power corrupts, absolute power
corrupts absolutely.
And Berlusconi turned parliament into his
backyard.
Plain and simple he passed laws tailor-made
for him.
For example, in 2004, Italy passed a law to
give financial aid for the purchase of digital
TV decoders.
Who had the main company that sold these devices?
Exactly!
Berlusconi's family.
And this is just one example in a very long
list: tax amnesties, financial regulations...
we could say that Silvio changed Italy to
make it fit his interests.
But now let's go to the most important thing
of all: the general picture.
What political outcome does Berlusconi leave
behind?
Apart from corruption...
Has he been good for the Italians?
Well, let's take a look right now.
(POWER FOR POWER'S SAKE)
Italy's economy is even worse than its political
class... and it makes no difference when you’re
hearing this.
Actually, Italy had a very good period in
the 1980s.
That is, when Berlusconi was building his
business empire, the country was on fire.
In the early 1990s, the Italians were richer
than the British and were close to catching
up with the Germans.
Now, however, Italy is in Europe's intensive
care unit.
One of the few countries that is now poorer
than it was 20 years ago.
And why, you may ask?
We have a couple of videos where we explain
it in detail: one from VisualPolitik and one
from VisualEconomik.
I’ll leave the link in the description.
But here is a brief summary.
Italy has systemic problems that make it almost
impossible for it to function.
It has a huge and totally inefficient State,
with more than 3 million civil servants and
a lot of public spending.
But that's not all!
One of Italy's great weaknesses is the most
absurd bureaucracy you can imagine.
For example, almost all the professions are
governed by regulatory colleges.
That means that if you want to work as a journalist
or computer scientist, you need a license.
And getting that license is a process that
seems to be from another era.
Well, with all these problems, Italy in the
1980s grew thanks to one thing: they were
addicted to devaluation.
Italy devalued its currency to make its products
cheaper on the international market.
During the 1980s and 1990s, "Made in Italy"
was sweeping Europe.
In the 2000s, China joined the World Trade
Organization and Italy joined the euro.
Conclusion: they could not compete with the
even cheaper prices of Chinese companies...
and they could not devaluate their currency
either.
It began a long crisis from which they have
not yet emerged.
However...
Silvio Berlusconi only wanted to win elections.
His political proposal?
For the good and against the bad.
What do Italians want?
To maintain the illusion that there are no
problems, nothing needs to be reformed, and
things will be fine.
Maintain public spending while the economy
sinks.
That is what Berlusconi has always promised
and what Berlusconi has achieved.
So what is the flipside of this policy?
Well you see, right now, Italy ranks 7th in
the world in debt to GDP and 5th in debt per
capita.
In fact, today, Italy is one of the biggest
headaches in all of Europe.
And in a way a good part of that is due to
what Berlusconi did, or rather did NOT do
despite having more power than almost any
other politician.
And what has Berlusconi done in recent years?
Well, the truth is that he has never abandoned
politics.
As we saw at the beginning, even at the age
of 84 he continued to run for election.
However, we can hardly find any interesting
political position... except this one.
(Silvio Berlusconi: Ex-PM defends Russian
war on eve of Italian election.
– BBC)
Exactly!
Berlusconi has been supporting Russia in the
Ukrainian war.
And why, you may ask?
Well, his argument was based on the fact that...
He knew Vladimir Putin personally and they
were very good friends.
In this case, it seems that Berlusconi's private
life DOES affect his political positions...
or so it appears from photos like this one.
Conclusion?
No one can deny that Berlusconi was a true
genius: a self-made man.
He managed to have more power than almost
any other man in history: he combined economic,
political and media power in the same person.
However, he used all that power in a mediocre
way, to say the least.
But now the questions are for you: Will we
ever see a new leader with as much power as
Berlusconi?
Are there other international leaders we could
compare with IL CAVALIERE?
And...
Would you like to reach 80-something years
of age with as much energy as Silvio?
You can leave me your answer in the comments.
As always, don't forget that here, on VisualPolitik,
we release new videos every week, so subscribe
to this channel and hit the little bell so
you don't miss any of our updates.
If you liked this video, LIKE it and see you
in the next one.
All the best and see you soon.